a good afternoon to you thank you so
much for joining us at four o'clock i'm
kirsten joyce and i'm christian casa it
is
new at four o'clock well we're talking
about coveted relief
funding and education the topic u.s
senator catherine cortez-mastro
addressed today while touring hancock
elementary school eight news now
reporter kristen drummond is live
outside the building with more on what
the effort and the community can expect
kristin
christian and kristen the senator
choosing this campus because
it's her alma mater she came here to not
only see
the first week back in full in-person
learning at all ccsd
elementary schools but also addressed
efforts to help all nevada schools
the senator was joined by state
superintendent joan ebert as well as
ccsd superintendent
dr jesus jarrah all three took a tour of
the campus to discuss
what's happening with the money from the
american rescue plan
she says more than one billion dollars
will come to nevada's public schools for
coveted relief
roughly 800 million of that is expected
to help the clark county school district
senator cortez masto says those federal
federal funds aim to support the mental
health of children
as we get them back in school we need to
make sure they have the long-term care
that they're going to need whether it's
in the form of counselors
or social workers
ccsd reports 23 students dying by
suicide since
last march the district does continue to
try and address mental health
a well-being screener called panorama
launched this school year for staff and
students
the lifeline program is also in nearly
70 schools
it's run by staff volunteers to address
students who may be in crisis
based on mental health surveys parent
calls or
academic performance now the new federal
funds may also address
the digital divide and coming up at five
o'clock see what dr jarrah plans to do
once the money does
come to ccsd reporting live outside
hancock elementary school i'm kristen
drummond 8 news now